[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of the
new film Palm Springs which you can now
watch on Hulu this is directed by max
Barba CO and written by Andy Sierra it's
also produced by Andy Samberg and he
stars in it with Cristin Milioti so Palm
Springs was one of the most interesting
watches I've had this year and I had a
lot of conflicting thoughts about it I
was actually so blown away by the first
45 minutes of this hour-and-a-half movie
I thought it was really good really
funny and quick with it as Andy Samberg
always is I'm a huge fan of samberg's
work especially hot rod and I think his
humor always lands most of the time but
this movie was getting some really
really high praise and I think it
deserves high praise but I don't think
it deserves the level where some critics
are saying that it's groundbreaking or
it's a game changer it's not that the
second half of the film falls into
familiar territory you've seen over and
over in rom-coms and that sort of
becomes a little disappointing I think
because it doubles up on an ending here
where you see when Niles see Sara's
missing and then he's going after her
and then she comes back and then she
leaves again to go in the cave because
they can't agree on whether to restart
this whole thing or not so it doubles up
on resolution in the last 45 minutes and
it kind of drags it in that sense where
it's more ROM than calm let's say and
that's fine that's preference I'm not
putting that against the film but it
also just gets a little boring in that
sense because it's so hard with the
rom-coms especially at the end here
they're so similar with how they resolve
everything but to do it for 45 minutes
just felt like too much and too long and
seeing him reveal at the bar that he's
missing the girl he's got her and after
we've seen that so many times so no it's
not a totally groundbreaking film I
think that's a little bit of overpraised
but I do believe that this Groundhog's
Day effect in the first 45 minutes
really shines and the humor just
absolutely crushes and I think the love
part of it does really well in the first
half as well something that really stood
out to me with this character Randy who
just dances hysterically at the wedding
he has some of the best lines in this
film like there's one sequel
was an earthquake at the wedding and
he's being held back and he's like I
should have never left the Great Lakes
this place is a nightmare or when at one
point Sara tries to set him up on
Misty's cheating and she gives him a
blindfold and he's like okay as long as
I can wear my shirt
it's just hysterical it makes no sense
and you see him walking in with a shirt
on it was just cause he's insecure it's
just great and from the top Andi simmers
always a joy to watch and his character
Niles is so much fun because you feel
him you feel his loneliness you feel his
dour outlook on the world and just
pretending not to care as they say and
he's got great lines here from the top
like 20 wakes up the first time the
first two times this season Miss Teen he
just says that's a good leg just I love
that about Andy Samberg he just can
present really funny lines like that and
I just maybe even laughed the hardest
movie just little beats he does where
when he first sees Sarah on the dance
floor but he's kind of like trying to
impress her dancing with everyone and he
mirrors that one guy I thought I was
just laughing my ass off and how I'm
saying the momentum here in the first
half was just extraordinary is then when
he goes and makes out with Sarah in the
desert and she's like can't get his
clothes off he's like yeah I got it and
then she's like you were underwear under
your bathing suit and then the arrow
from JK Simmons hits him I thought that
was just brilliant timing comedic timing
I loved that whole sequence and I'm
talking about this awesome pacing and
just not letting go where once Sarah's
in the loop and you we as the audience
figure out that this is the choice that
it's like a groundhog set up then you
get really funny moments just coming in
and out which I love and I'm dying back
and forth and just seeing towel on her
wedding day fall at the pool and her
teeth just get destroyed was great and
they just threw so many quick-witted
lines in the beginning like just Darla
this character at the bar when Niles
says at the bar
I vow to never bring anyone to this life
again I'm Darla just says back amen to
that I got my tubes tied when I was 40
that was just so good and the desert
setting really worked here for the film
being about two lost souls here
colliding and the character of Sarah was
great as well just like Niles where
there's a bleak outlook on life she's
very anti marriage not because she used
to be in a marriage doesn't believe in
it anymore doesn't really believe in
love and they both hit a point midway
here where they just completely don't
give a crap but they do a good back and
forth with the two of them where Sarah
starts bringing up with him why won't
you talk about your past that's part of
the package
and he's so in denial about it but then
it flips and then he's really the one
who's falling head-over-heels for her
and finally puts down his shell but she
starts running away and starts facing
the other twist yet that she had an
affair with her sister's husband which
was cool they hinted that too because
every time she woke up you heard the
shower a little longer so you can kind
of connect the dots s someone was in
that shower and it was important and I
really do think in the love aspect the
romantic aspect of this film it worked
the best even the sequence when Sarah
was saying denials about knowing about
each other's past and how it's important
and he's kind of resisting and they're
both on mushrooms and they see the
dinosaurs there was something about her
grabbing his hand there that really hid
well that first time you hold hand with
someone you like I thought that was
really effective and I just wish they
kept that effectiveness and hitting
these just sparks of moments that didn't
feel tired in other amantha commies have
been done so much that kind of end up
being what happens towards the end which
I think was a lil disappointing but I
did really appreciate how they handled
it in the first half and they did really
have just good twists constantly and you
can add that too and there's a big
character moment when Niles admits that
well accidentally admits that he had
actually slept with Sarah a bunch before
and didn't tell her that so they both
have obviously their skeletons they have
to eventually seeing each other and that
wraps out well at the end when Niles has
a line about he's seen her full package
and it's good and that that's important
and he has that character turn around
and Sarah's being that she's giving love
a chance again but they write Sarah well
here she has that important line at the
end where she's like I could still
survive on my own I don't actually need
you but it helps life be less mundane so
it's a very progressive updated take on
love which I appreciate it as well
I thought the shining moment though in
the second half was actually the scene
with JK Simmons is Roy where Niles goes
to see him and his family and one of the
best lines in the movie is he's talking
about his son and he goes little Joey's
watering [ __ ] that's weird I was so
funny but where it drags is right after
this again where Sarah starts trying to
figure out how to use this donkey to
teleport and it becomes this just
resolution feeding act where it's tough
when you set up a movie to be the climax
for half of the movie
and I think again that's what makes you
feel a little bored here but I'm not
totally against the second half I just
again wish it was a little more original
and I do think the last scene worked
really well not when they're in the pool
but right before she's about to walk in
the cave with him
I like how they did she gives him one
sentence and he has to extend that one
sentence so he's adding all these
different commas exclamation points oh
just to extend the sentence longer that
was really funny and worked and it
hitting that theme if he'd rather die
with you blowing up in this cave then
living in this world without you so kind
of hitting that we all need somebody in
the end so it the matically gives you
that payoff as well the writing has a
goal where it wants to get to and it
effectively gets there but it's almost
like the first half so good that
actually makes the second half look a
little weaker so it's hard to pull that
off the whole way through I just wish
they kept that momentum they kept more
comedy in the second half and they just
got a little more original like they did
in the first half with the second half
and stay away from kind of the tropes of
a lot of romantic comedies that we've
seen like him running after her them
doubling up on an end here dragging out
the runtime without giving as much
creative thought so that will bring a
little points down for me but I still
thought it was really really well done
and a lot of funny moments so I'm giving
this one an eight point eight let me
know what you thought of it down below
I'd love to hear your thoughts I read
every comment try to respond as many as
I can please make sure to subscribe I
can use any subscriber can get trying to
hit 30,000 one of my dream has always
been Rotten Tomatoes approved critic if
I can get to 30 I can hopefully get to
getting approved for that so I can use
any help I can get I appreciate every
single one of you and if you could share
my reviews that will also help as well
and please follow me at Steve rd1 on
Twitter Instagram for more of me and
I'll see you next time